alrighty so meanwhile facebook and
twitter appearing on the hill
and you can see the different agendas of
the republicans and democrats when it
comes to facebook and twitter
republicans are saying
you guys really should allow people to
speak their minds on your platforms
i mean this is what your platforms were
created for and democrats are like you
know what you should really do you
should use your massive social media
power to ensure
that no one is ever able to express
their opinion if we don't like their
opinion
it's incredibly obvious that democrats
are seeking to
enjoin conservatives from expressing
their opinion or disseminating
information they don't
like so richard blumenthal idiot
senator from connecticut he actually
demanded that mark zuckerberg
ban steve bannon and zuckerberg is like
do you have like grounds for banning
steve bannon
and and blumenthal's like i don't like
him we're not gonna like what if we just
don't let them on on the system that'd
be great democrats
see social media as a way of quashing
their opposition and they are angry
that places like facebook allow their
opposition to exist
so they've made it impossible for any
republican the media have made it
impossible for any open republican
to work at a mainstream publication and
then when you form
a different kind of publication like
daily wire and you disseminate your
information
through social media like twitter or
facebook democrats are like you know
it'd be great if we shut that down too
here's richard blumenthal trying to do
this yesterday how many times does steve
bannon allowed
the call for the murder of government
officials before
facebook suspends his account
senator as you say the content in
question did violate our policies and we
took it down
will you commit to taking down that
account steve bannon's account
senator no it's that that's not what our
policies would suggest that we should do
again zuckerberg at least is being
consistent there you can see how he's
getting brow beaten
by members of the democratic party which
is the great irony here what you are
seeing
from facebook's internals well what
you're seeing from from the leaked
reports about what's going on inside
facebook
is that facebook is being bullied by the
left to comply with the left
in the assumption that people on the
right are going to be in favor of free
speech and free enterprise and defend
them even as they quash speech from the
right
it ain't gonna happen it ain't gonna
happen anyway chris coons from delaware
right he does the same thing
he says i want facebook and i want
twitter to censor climate denialism he
says can you guys please
you know shut down anybody's ability to
speak about their doubts about
climate change solutions proposed by the
left the democrats are
all in favor of censorship you think
these are your free speech protectors
good luck
you do mr dorsey have um policies
against
uh deep fakes or manipulated media
against covet 19 misinformation against
things that violate civic integrity but
if you don't have a standalone climate
change
misinformation policy i'd urge you to
reconsider that because
helping uh to disseminate climate
denialism in my view
um further facilitates and accelerates
one of the greatest existential threats
to our world
okay i mean this is crazy so he's saying
that if you don't agree with my
perspective on climate change i want
woke rasputin over here jack dorsey
to actually stop that information from
being disseminated the democrats are
very clear in what they want here
the democrats are very clear they want a
single party system a single party
dominating
your methods of informational
dissemination this is how they got your
biden elected
this is what they hope to do they hope
to use social media
as a weapon to siphon off all of the
possible
information they don't like and make it
and make it go away disappear into the
ether
democrats cannot be trusted with free
speech principles if they had their way
you would not be able to listen to shows
like this one and you're going to see
this weaponized
not just by social media companies
you're going to see it weaponized by
credit card companies there will come a
point here here's my prediction there
will come a point in which credit card
companies
under pressure from woke staffers and
from members of democratic congress
decide that they are simply not going to
allow you to charge on your credit card
anything they don't like
so if you decide that you're going to
subscribe to daily wire there will come
a point where your credit card company
says you can't because they're
conservative and we don't like that
or you want to buy a gun with your
credit card a credit card company will
say nope you can't do that you can't use
your charge card for that
the predictable result of that will be
that there will be right-wing credit
cards and left-wing credit cards
the left is so determined to wish
everybody they don't like out into the
cornfield all they're going to do is
create entire new
right-wing ecosystems that's all that's
going to happen there will be two
parallel systems
you'll only be able to go to the
right-wing restaurant or the left-wing
restaurant
you'll only be able to go to the
right-wing credit card or the left-wing
credit card you don't you're only going
to be able to go over to powerlord
because twitter is going to ban you
right i mean this is the way
that the left wants things to be and
then they complain that those
alternative systems even exist right
they complain that parlor is even a
thing
they're whining about how so many people
are joining parlor yes it turns out when
you weaponize a social media company
against people you disagree with
those people will leave and go find an
alternative method of talking with one
another
maisie hirono the stupidest person in
the united states energy is a complete
and utter dud
intellectually and the the senator from
hawaii she slammed facebook
why because they allowed the daily
caller fact-checking site to be included
in their fact checkers now as i have
mentioned when it comes to social media
social media do something deeply corrupt
they outsource
all of their political predilections to
the fact checkers so what they do is
they go to politifact or snopes
or factcheck.org all left-wing sites the
washington post fact checker all
left-wing sites who
very often are not even checking facts
very often these fact checks will say
things like
well sure what the republican was saying
here was was factually true but it packs
a false narrative
and then they will use that as a
rationale for downgrading
particular news sites so we've had this
experience with for example there's a
site called newsguard
newsguard has downgraded our site not
because what we report is false
but we report things that are mistaken
sometimes just like cnn does
they've downgraded us because we are
openly an opinion site that also does
news reporting
so what they do these social media
companies they outsource to places like
newsguard
to decide whether an outlet is good or
not and naturally a newsguard decides
that leftwing outlets
and establishment media outlets those
are good and everybody on the right is
bad okay so they're doing the same thing
with the fact checkers
facebook actually does allow one
quote-unquote right-wing fact checker
that'd be the daily caller maisie
hirono's like
well we shouldn't allow that there
shouldn't be any fact checkers on the
right and in fact the daily caller is a
white supremacist site which of course
the daily caller is not but maisie
hirono isn't
is a complete so here she is early
in 2019
facebook selected the daily caller
another site with white nationalist
ties to be one of his third party fact
checkers
and this is that where i i'm really
wondering at one point
at what point you will stop giving in to
basis claims of anti-conservative bias
and start exercising
your control over facebook to stop
driving division and actually support
you
build community and bring the world
closer
it's ridiculous so they want to make
sure that all the fact checkers are left
doing fact checkers so that they can
launder their left wing views
through the fact checkers and then just
say hey look the fact checkers say the
site's bad so we're just not going to
allow
the site anymore how how ridiculous is
maisie toronto she cited media matters
to suggest that facebook and twitter are
not biased against conservatives
media matters commedia matters is a is a
political action organization
started by hillary clinton and david
brock with the explicit design of
protecting the clintons
it is a it is an organization that
dedicates its time
to listening to shows like this one
clipping things out of context and then
attempting to make them trend via echo
chamber on twitter so they can go after
advertisers they're a left-wing front
group
okay they've always been a left-wing
group the attempt to use media matters
is some sort of objective
news verifier when it comes to facebook
and twitter like
hey if media matters says that that
facebook and twitter aren't biased
against conservatives well then it must
be true
can that that's legitimately like me
citing the epic times to the idea
that left-wingers never experienced
hardship in the united states like what
are you talking about that's an overtly
partisan group it's not like to make any
bones about it here's maizie hirono
being an idiot as
she is want to do everyone who has
systematically looked at the
content of social media from
media matters to the cato institute to
former republican senator john tyle
has found absolutely no evidence of
anti-conservative bias
and data from proud tangle show that
far right content from the likes of fox
news
ben shapiro david bongino dominates the
daily top
10 most engaged pages
on facebook okay well the reason that we
dominate on facebook is because there
are like three of us
if you actually look at these sites that
have the most traffic
via via facebook it is at least mostly
establishment media sites right it is it
is mainstream media sites that is that
is what they are right
they get a lot of their traffic from
facebook they spend millions of dollars
on facebook every month
and the the idea that that right wingers
are not biased against on facebook i can
tell i can tell you this
you can look at the quote unquote top 10
in terms of reach the reach on my page
has been artificially suppressed over
the last two months okay this is
perfectly clear we can see it happening
in real time
and the reason it was suppressed is
because people like maisie hirono and
kevin roose decided they were going to
yell at facebook until they suppress
that so
the people who have not yet been
suppressed are people like dan bongino
right dan
knows that it's coming for him too which
is why he has started alternative social
media sites but this is the whole point
the whole point is that the democratic
left does not want you to be able
to consume information that you are
interested in consuming
and the woke staffers inside these
various organizations are all for it
they're all for
the use of these social media platforms
as ways to cram down
the left-wing point of view right this
is a point
that uh that ted cruz made to jack
dorsey because dorsey has been labeling
things misinformation on voter fraud so
cruz was like um so are you an expert on
voter fraud
why is it that only some posts get
labeled misinformation on voter fraud
and not others
does voter fraud exist i
i don't know for certain are you an
expert in voter fraud
no i'm not well why then is twitter
right now
putting purported warnings on
virtually any statement about voter
fraud
we're we're simply linking to a broader
conversation so that people have more
information
no no you're not you put up a page that
says quote voter fraud of any kind is
exceedingly rare in the united states
that's not linking to a broader
conversation that's taking
a disputed policy position and you're a
publisher when you're doing that
okay so ted is exactly right about this
of course senator cruz when he says that
you guys are taking the position
as i said yesterday my business partner
tweeted out something overtly false
about stacey abrams being governor of
georgia
not flagged by twitter if you say that
there's widespread voter fraud in the
united states that is flagged as false
by twitter so
twitter obviously has its own point of
view on things they're entitled to that
but let's not pretend that they are some
sort of neutral arbiter of information
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button